the left knows that free speech is the
biggest threat to its plans to control
everything starting with the White House
in a year so they're doing whatever they
can to suppress speech this is true even
on brace yourself
knitting websites Ravelry is a social
networking site dedicated to knitting
it's got more than eight million members
most of them probably reasonable decent
people this week though the company the
company banned users from expressing any
support for the President of the United
States their point is the position of 63
million American voters is quote white
supremacy if the ban works and
conservatives do nothing which is
basically what they always do nothing
expect other websites to do exactly the
same thing and your freedom to erode a
little bit more what's the Francis
Cohoes outnumbered as well as after the
Bell and Fox Business one of the
smartest people in the building and she
joins us tonight Melissa are you on this
website revelry yeah so so I I don't
even get the pun because I know nothing
about knitting so that part of it is
sort of lost but but but I did go and
check the whole thing out and and it's
right up there on the front of their
website it says it's this is done in the
spirit of inclusiveness that's how it
starts there including people that's why
they're doing this it says we cannot
provide a space that is inclusive of all
and also allow support for open white
supremacy and you're like okay if you
want to make people feel at home and
good about their knitting you can't have
open white supremacy but then the next
line it says support of the Trump
administration is undeniably support for
white supremacy so half of America now
are white supremacy premises then they
hedge a little bit and they say you can
still participate you just can't talk
about it here you know like okay I I'm
so confused by this policy I must dig
deeper and it begs an obvious question
what could have possibly led to this was
there some huge incident I mean I
haven't seen a lot of crocheted mega
hats around I don't see a lot of
mufflers that say you know Keep America
great haven't seen these things so I
called and I emailed and we've been
trying to get in contact so is the New
York Times so as everybody else who's
written about this and I've read every
article there are no quotes from this
company anywhere and there is no
indication of
the incident that brought this about so
you think to yourself hmm I hope this
isn't like a Jessie Smollett type
situation where they're just trying to
draw attention to themselves and get
national media attention by putting up
this policy on their website well
they're not coming out and telling us
about anything that happened there's no
evidence of it anywhere so I have to
wonder if it's just brilliant marketing
when you go to their Twitter page it has
a black lives matter sign on the top and
they obviously have a political leaning
and maybe they know their customer well
I mean I may be cynical but maybe they
know their customer well and that's what
they're after
PR there you go well I know a lot of
knitters I don't know any of them who
are radical I mean politicizing
everything has a cost after a while does
it not we can't have nice things anymore
Tucker what's the Frances you're the
best great to see you